remember this
[Music]
that's one of the Ukrainian Defenders of
snake island a tiny but strategically
pivotal island in the Black Sea he was
talking to the mosqueva the largest
vessel in Russia's Black Sea Fleet on
the first day of the war
bombarded and captured snake island but
just a few weeks later it lay ruined on
the seabed
how did Ukraine get its revenge and sink
Russia's flagship
at 186 meters long the mosque vote was
two-thirds the length of the Titanic
armed with 16 huge missile launchers and
radar that could scan hundreds of
kilometers it was the most advanced
vessel in the Black Sea no one believed
she could be sunk
but the ukrainians had a secret weapon
the Neptune anti-ship cruise missile
designed to skim just above the surface
of the Waves it had a chance of evading
the moscow's defense systems
accounts differ on how exactly the most
vote was located the Ukrainian Navy says
low cloud cover that day increased the
range of its radar systems but experts
have suggested they may have been helped
by Western Intelligence on April 13th
Ukraine fired two Neptune missiles at
the moscva through some combination of
inexperienced faulty equipment or sheer
complacency the mosque of his crew
failed to spot the incoming threat the
missiles scored a direct hit
the sinking of the Moscow was a turning
point in the war without the air defense
the Moscow provided Ukraine could harass
Russian ships with drones and missiles
in June 2022 Ukraine retook Snake Island
for the first time since the start of
the war Ukraine's Coast was Secure from
invasion